[Música]
la oficina de inteligencia de eeuu
responsabilizó al príncipe heredero de
arabia saudita mohamed bin salman del
asesinato del periodista llaman a scioli
en 2018 según el informe de la cia bin
salman valido la operación en estambul
para capturarlo o matarlo real y
estrechas o las acusaciones tenemos
análisis en esta emisión
la cámara de representantes de eeuu
aprobó la madrugada de este sábado del
presupuesto de 1,9 billones de dólares
promovido por el presidente joe biden y
destinado a aliviar la crisis económica
causada por la pandemia de escribir 19
el proyecto que representa la primera
victoria parlamentaria de bairén pasará
ahora al senado tenemos reportes desde
washington
y en nigeria fueron liberadas 42
personas que permanecían en cautiverio
tras ser secuestradas hace 10 días en la
localidad de [__] a estrelló son 27
estudiantes también avanzar el país
africano el operativo de rescate de las
317 niñas que fueron secuestradas el
viernes pero el poblado de anged
actualizamos la información de américa
latina y del mundo aquí entra el 24 mi
nombre es liliana valencia iniciamos
hablando del caso yo vi porque luego de
que la agencia central de inteligencia
de estados unidos acusara a mohamed bin
salman heredero a la corona de arabia
saudita de aprobar el asesinato del
periodista llama al hub y las reacciones
no se han hecho esperar
el ministerio de exteriores de arabia
saudita calificó el informe de falso
inaceptable e inexacto y el príncipe
niega haber ordenado el asesinato
ocurrido en el consulado saudita de
estambul en turquía en 2018
eeuu emitió sanciones contra más de 70
sauditas pero no contra el príncipe bin
salman
para realizar esta información nos
comunicamos con marino aguirre mariano
aguirre investigador del instituto yad
man house de londres bienvenida france24
y cuéntanos cuál es el objetivo del
presidente joe biden al publicar este
informe que revive el caso falsos
muchas gracias por invitarme básicamente
eeuu lo que hace con esto es lanzar
primero un mensaje coherentemente con la
campaña lo que dijo durante su campaña
el presidente baile en el sentido de que
eeuu vuelve a tomar en cuenta la
cuestión de los derechos humanos en el
mundo
en segundo lugar hace un juego de alguna
manera de equilibrios entre e irán con
el que está tratando de volver a
negociar el regreso de eeuu y que irán
pare su programa nuclear
por el momento civil pero que podría ser
militar pero al mismo tiempo le da un
mensaje a irán de que no va a ser sólo
lo que arabia saudi quiera que su gran
enemigo en la región y arabia saudí le
dice vamos a contar con ustedes pero
también no van a poder ustedes
hacer o por decir así indicarnos cuál es
nuestra política como ocurría durante la
época de trump y es de alguna manera un
tercer mensaje indirecto también así
israel
que en este momento es un aliado no
declarado pero gran aliado de arabia
saudi diciéndole nosotros nos vamos a
volver a la era tram o no queremos estar
en la era donde hacíamos lo que ustedes
nos dictaba bueno pero una vez conocido
el informe la cia eeuu sancionó a más de
70 saudíes pero no al príncipe bin
salman siguen mediando intereses entre
ambas naciones entendiendo que como
usted también no lo explicaba área
saudita es un aliado clave en esta
región y perdón si efectivamente estados
unidos cuenta con arabia saudí desde
hace varias décadas es un gran comprador
de armas
es un país que está en ese equilibrio
que se creó hace varias décadas que
tiene eeuu entre israel egipto arabia
saudí y en este momento básicamente eeuu
quiere calibrar de calibrar su situación
en la región una región en la que está
perdiendo peso y tiene que ver cómo
conciliar de alguna manera
cómo conciliar a la vida saudí y cómo
considerar también a turquía y a israel
todo esto es un juego muy difícil y en
el que entre cómo se logra explicar esto
que la decisión que acaba de tomar pues
agradecemos la opinión de mariano
aguirre investigador del instituto
schattmann house de londres y
continuamos en eeuu porque la cámara de
representantes aprobó el paquete de
ayudas promovido por el presidente joe
biden para paliar la crisis económica
causada por las medidas contra el kobe
19 por un monto de 1,9 billones de
dólares con 219 votos a favor y 212 en
contra la cámara de mayoría demócrata le
dio luz verde a la propuesta que ya fue
enviada al senado donde también deberá
ser votada el presupuesto sería
destinado al pago de vacunas y
suministros médicos e incluye también un
pago directo a hogares y empresas por
1.400 dólares además de un beneficio de
desempleo federal de 400 dólares por
semana hasta el próximo 29 de agosto
ampliamos esta información con nuestro
corresponsal en washington y cristóbal
vázquez
buenos días y cuéntenos esta sería la
primera victoria parlamentaria de joe
bailes desde que asumió el poder que se
espera entonces de la votación de este
proyecto en el senado
si es que los demócratas tienen una
mayoría marginal a tanto en la cámara
representantes como en el senado y este
proyecto entonces ahora pasa al senado
donde va a necesitar una mayoría simple
51 votos porque pasa como una ley de
presupuesto de reconciliación y así los
demócratas pues contarían con esos 51
votos teniendo en cuenta el voto de
kamala harris normalmente se necesitan
60 votos para poder aprobar este tipo de
iniciativas pero precisamente como es
una ley de reconciliación necesitará 51
solamente al respecto los republicanos
han dicho que este presupuesto es
bastante alto y que además es muy
general y por eso la oposición que
tendrá este proyecto de parte de los
republicanos en la cámara alta
hay que mencionar que después de ser
aprobado por el senado el proyecto de
ayuda de rescate económica de 19
billones de dólares volverá a la
de representantes para un visto final y
después ir a la oficina del presidente
para que sea firmado como le he visto al
ver uno de los temas principales del
debate en cuanto a esta ley fue el
aumento del salario promovido por los
demócratas en qué consiste la propuesta
y cómo quedó entonces esta es la
votación
claro la propuesta es aumentar el
salario mínimo en eeuu a 15 dólares para
el 2025 sobre todo para las grandes
empresas sin embargo este proyecto no va
a poder pasar en el senado porque
precisamente ayer la parlamentaria
elisabetta mcdonald le dijo a los
demócratas que en una ley de presupuesto
no se puede incluir este tema del
aumento salarial que es que va contra
las reglas del senado y la propia casa
blanca ya lo reconoció y dijo que
efectivamente pues sino en contra de las
reglas y que no iba a hacer nada al
respecto que simplemente se iba a
aferrar a las reglas y asumir esto como
una derrota lo que están haciendo
entonces los demócratas es empezar a
buscar soluciones a pesar de que sabían
que era que iba contra las reglas los
demócratas de la cámara de
representantes aprueban el salario
mínimo y lo aprueban como dice analistas
para que el tema esté en la mesa de
negociación para que sea un debate que
se tenga que dar y lo que ellos quieren
entonces es
como solución empezar a poner
penalidades a las empresas grandes que
no paguen los 15 dólares la obra o
cobrarles más impuestos para que los
americanos pues puedan según ellos
recibir un salario mínimo así que no les
que les permite a vivir con este salario
y no tengan que trabajar para seguir en
la pobreza gracias a nuestro
corresponsal en washington cristóbal
vázquez y seguimos en haití porque luego
de la masiva fuga de la cárcel de quad
de buque el pasado jueves que dejó 25
muertos incluido el director del centro
penitenciario y el jefe de una poderosa
pandilla las autoridades siguen buscando
a más de 200 reclusos después de que 400
subieran del centro penitenciario de
puerto príncipe la capital del país
tratando de recuperar el control después
de la evasión carcelaria más grande y
mortífera de haití en una década las
autoridades están recorriendo el país en
busca de cientos de fugitivos el jueves
más de 400 reclusos lograron huir de la
cárcel y 787 que tenía casi el doble de
su capacidad de reclusos antes del
incidente había mil 542 personas en la
prisión del quad de ugt después de los
controles realizados hoy vemos mil 125
presos que están en prisión entre los
fugitivos que la policía logró localizar
se encontraba uno de los principales
líderes de pandillas en haití en el
josep el más buscado por las autoridades
del país hasta su arresto en 2019 bajo
cargos que incluían violación secuestro
y homicidio
josep ya había intentado escapar en
julio pero esta vez fue detectado en un
puesto de control y murió tras un
tiroteo con la policía durante la fuga
otros presos fueron asesinados al igual
que varios transeúntes y el director de
la penitenciaría en twitter el
presidente de jouvenel moix condenó el
hecho y le pidió a la policía usar todas
las medidas necesarias esta no es la
primera vez que los reclusos escapan de
las cárceles de haití en 2014 de la
misma prisión construida con
de canadá se escaparon 300 condenados
antes de eso durante el devastador
terremoto en haití en 2010 más de 4.000
prisioneros huyeron en el caos que
siguió al desastre natural seguimos con
nuestra serie de los recicladores
indispensables pero no invisibles hoy
vamos a españa donde miles de personas
migrantes se dedican a recoger chatarra
en las calles de barcelona como modo de
subsistencia este reportaje hace parte
de la serie de publicaciones el
resultado de la beca de producción
periodística sobre reciclaje inclusivo
ejecutada con el apoyo de la fundación
gabo y latitud r este es un informe de
judí de alonso massa y si javier su ley
héctor tiene 28 años y lleva 3
recogiendo chatarra en las calles de
barcelona es una de las miles de
personas que sobreviven con esta
actividad en la que un buen día de
trabajo pueden llegar a ganar hasta 15
euros
aunque es español aquí la mayoría de los
recicladores son personas migrantes sin
papeles procedentes de áfrica
sub-sahariana
que buscan normalmente la chatarra o
gente que duerme en la calle o
extranjeros que no tienen recursos y
desde hace mucho desde hace cinco años
atrás ahora hay mucho el doble de gente
buscando que antes héctor vende los
materiales a karim un senegalés que
llegó a españa en 2006 empezó siendo
chatarrero y ahora gestiona está
chatarrería donde cada día recibe cerca
de 200 recicladores para escoger una
cara de 300 kilos el campo no va hasta
aquí cuando que la metro va a ser tú
más duro
y los 365 días tu no para no es duro
encima no puedes ganar algo puede decir
que tengo dinero no es duro es muy duro
para sobrevivir llegó aquí lo tengo
papel no puede trabajar esta población
invisible contribuye al sector de
reciclaje de metales que mueve 10 mil
millones de euros al año en españa se
estima que aportan casi una tercera
parte de la chatarra que se recicla en
cataluña no obstante nadie sabe cuántos
hay ni cuál es su contribución a la
economía están fuera del sistema
institucional de reciclaje pero se
consciente su actividad dan un servicio
a la sociedad de forma gratuita porque
las empresas privadas cobran para
recoger gestionar transportar y reciclar
esos materiales y los legisladores
informales de alguna forma hacen algo
parecido pero no cobran nada del estado
y claramente hacen un servicio que
también es un servicio ambiental para
federico de maría una opción sería
formalizar los siguiendo el ejemplo de
algunos lugares de américa latina a
través de cooperativas
y las miles de personas que sobreviven
de la chatarra en la ciudad sería un
paso adelante
en nigeria se confirmó la liberación de
las 42 personas secuestradas la semana
pasada 25 de ellas estudiantes
entretanto las autoridades continúan con
el operativo para localizar a las 317
niñas que fueron raptadas el jueves por
hombres armados que irrumpieron en el
internado donde estudiaban
sin noticias de sus hijas secuestradas
en la noche del jueves al viernes
hombres armados irrumpieron en este
internado dejé nieve en el estado de
zamfara y secuestraron a 317 alumnas de
secundaria los enfrentamientos entre los
asaltantes y las fuerzas de seguridad
fueron violentos y se han escapado uno
de ellos abandonó su moto en la huida
fue entonces cuando pensamos que íbamos
a detenerlos luego nos dijeron que
volviéramos a casa y ahora mientras
hablo
los soldados están luchando contra ellos
en el mundo el gobierno federal envió
allí fuerzas fuertemente armadas y
actualmente inspeccionan la zona el
presidente mohamed dibujar y ordenó la
operación y anunció que no cederá ante
el chantaje ni pagará el rescate las
autoridades locales han anunciado el
cierre de todos los internados de la
región hasta nuevo aviso y acusan al
gobierno central de no proteger
suficientemente a sus ciudadanos
walt whitman
apreciamos los esfuerzos del gobierno
federal en la lucha contra los vándalos
y otras actividades delictivas en el
estado y deseo solicitar un mayor apoyo
en la lucha contra este desafío
combaten de esta ley
por el momento se desconoce la identidad
de los secuestradores en la zona operan
varias bandas armadas
las familias lloran a sus hijos
desaparecidos una escena cada vez más
habitual en el norte de nigeria en
diciembre pasado encantará a más de 200
kilómetros de distancia 300 adolescentes
fueron secuestrados durante la noche y
liberados poco después los secuestros
masivos son motivados para obtener lucro
a través de los rescates y en ocasiones
vinculados a los yihadistas de boko
haram así finalizamos quédense con
nosotros
[Música]
r efe